[Music]
happy birthday mr. adults man Omaha
black gross what was dad like his beard
was scratchy he had a goofy laugh I wish
I'd bet him I have something for you
from your dad
it's a wizard set
I wrote this spell so I can see for
myself who my boys grew up to me
the spell brings him back back way back
to life he wanted to meet you more than
anything
dad stop art dad you are in your house
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean
Cori she's over there that's the
manticore trouble big time get in the
vehicle I'm escorting yo I'm giving you
to the count of three okay wait what are
you doing I don't know I'm looking for
my sons
oh they went on a quest but don't worry
I told him about the map I told them
about the gym I told them about the
curse huh I forgot your boys are in
great danger
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you boys doing a crank
their project not great
[Applause]
I can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this I've seen you
what cutt knows where to go don't you
boy yes your room
on my way boys just stay out of trouble
[Music]
long ago the world was full of wonder it
was adventurous there was magic
but it wasn't easy to master
so the world found a simpler way to get
by but I hope there's a little magic
left in you there dad said to give you
this when you were both over 16
it's a wizard step dad was a wizard your
dad was an accountant this spell
brings him back what back way back to
life that's not possible it is with this
I'm gonna meet dad Oh
dad of 24 hours to bring the rest of
them back we're going on
[Music]
I think we should take the path a barrel
but these first ladies bastard know the
long run fine dad gotta go
[Music]
there could be booby traps
before you cast a spell again you're
gonna have to practice doubles out beep
apart back looks like the house
we need spell that creates a magical
bridge you can walk on if you believe
the bridge is there then it's there you
can do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey get back to work
lay down
Sardi's I didn't get a chance to walk
her bad dragon
that's your lair destiny oh it's okay
I'm coming I'm coming
I see you brought sustenance for our
adventure no it's garbage for the
trashcan and you left the lid off get
out here
unicorns
[Music]
oh yes boss
it's not quest it's just a really fast
and strange errand it's totally a quest
[Music]